right so um third question here um you
know language learning is a lot about
memorization of course we have to learn
new words new phrases and idioms and so
forth um you know language like Japanese
for example the words are going to be
very different from uh you know English
or other romance languages um how do you
do it how do you memorize new words and
phrases do you have any techniques do
you learn in chunks or do you learn like
lists of words how do you do
it okay that's very interesting question
um now um you know a lot of people focus
on and they talk about acquiring words
and that's important because words are
the bricks of uh that make out the wall
so to say the language wall um I have
various techniques for that and it
really depends on the phase I am in um
for example when I'm a beginner when I'm
when I start learning a language and do
something when I uh I use this back and
forth
translation um when when I'm in an
intermediate phase I do something else
and when I'm Advanced I do something uh
different so basically um to make a long
story short I use this bilingual uh
bilingual text and use this back and
forth translation to to learn words in
chunks I believe and this goes for
pronunciation intonation and grammar
words that we learn languages uh in
chunks that means that for example kids
learn not only the words but they learn
how to pronounce the a whole sentence by
hearing chunks uh of the language uh the
main difference when people say that uh
adults uh learn differently uh they
learn differently because you're they're
also taught to learn differently for
example you go to language school and
you have the teacher who shows you uh
how do you say hand and everybody
repeats hand so they teach you words in
isolation but the truth is that for
example the phonetic configuration of a
word changes according to its position
in a sentence so not even it's not only
a matter of pronunciation so you learn
to pronounce single words but then you
don't know how to put them together or
your procity is wrong but it's also a
matter of learning in chunks and in
context so uh what I do is I always use
bilingual I I believe that your L1 is a
valuable tool to learn another language
but because you can always use this as a
crutch to understand what you're
learning what is unknown to you but you
learn in Chu I believe that a language
is a net so every time uh I uh strongly
suggest you not only you not concentrate
focus on single words but you always
have to find these words in in in
context that means that you learn words
from sentences um and I believe that
this is extremely important so what I do
when I use this back and forth
translation I always translate I always
focus on messages on that are contained
in sentences and I learned and I learn
words in as a consequence of that so
this is at the beginning when you don't
know pretty much anything of the
language I use this back and forth
translation it helps me a lot because it
helps me notice uh my mistakes when I
translate back but it also makes me
remember words because I want to convey
a message I read a text I find the
content interesting if I find it
interesting a dialogue naturally and
when I when when I have already
translated into my native tongue and I
try to translate it back a few days
later I want to convey a message so my
my desire to say again what I have heard
in a sentence in context helps me uh
helps helps enormously and helps me you
know the words just stick as a
consequence of wanting to um com you
know wanting to say something to uh to
transmit a message and that is extremely
important because it's a brain friendly
way of learning a language you learn it
because it's a tool Tool uh you want to
talk even if you don't want to talk
directly you want to talk to somebody
you're still trying to uh convey a
message and learning is a consequence of
that while people want to learn
deliberately and they try to uh you know
learn words they have a list of words
and they repeat words over and over um
as I said before it's not only what you
do but also the time schedule so if you
do it in a certain way and you respect a
certain time schedule according to this
forgetting because we forget things
pretty quickly if you can revise it in a
certain way and you always keep in mind
that you want to convey a message um
learning and memorizing words will be a
consequence of that action and they will
stick for good in your longterm memory
instead of trying to deliberately learn
words uh in isolation or even words in
context that's the technique I've
applied and that's a principle abide by
because even if techniques very VAR
according to the phase I am in in I
always respect this principle to to
learn words in context and to choose
something interesting that I want to
talk about later by using the words that
I'm learning so you found that basically
writing you know at the actual writing
process where you're actually
translating the the sentences and
everything you found that this really
helps in memorizing because you both
have the context the emotions and you
know you're you're getting even
physically involved in writing the text
so you found that this helps a lot it
helps a lot um you don't you don't
necessarily have to uh when you when you
translate back um I've never talked
about this I believe you never you don't
necessarily have to translate it by
writing it you can also translate it by
uh just saying it out loud um orally but
the difference is that if you trans if
you if you write it you will see uh you
will learn how to write appropriately
and you will create a bond between the
written word and the sounds which is
very important that's the reason why
every time I speak I see subtitles in my
mind so every time I speak even English
to guide my pronunciation because my
brain creates a bond between the sound
and the the written words the written
word now somebody might say that we
learn languages like as kids we learn to
we hear the language first and then we
learn how to write but since we are
adults and we can use our eyes and ears
so we can read something we can take
advantage of what we have and I believe
that if a language has a script like a
lot of language the most of the
languages I've been Le well actually all
the languages that I've learned so far
you can use texts so you can read a text
while uh you listen to it to create this
bond which is very powerful pretty
interesting so it's a bit like the
website link.com where you have the
audio and um also the text at the same
time or audio books that you can
download or buy you know uh on websites
yeah that's something you would Rec
that's that's that's the reason why I I
find uh websites like uh link uh very
very important because um you know they
provide interesting content especially
for intermediate Learners especially in
that phase where you can um you know
read and listen um a lot of people find
it difficult to understand for example I
some some people ask me how can you
understand the radio the fact is that um
um written words uh when people speak
they aggregate they put words together
because the the number of sounds that
come out from your mouth are different
from the number of written words you
know when we say I'm happy and I want to
go there you say I'm happy just one
sound and I want to go there so that
makes it difficult for a person who's
not used to hearing that language it's
is just you know jumble Mumble you
cannot you cannot make out the single
sounds and some people might say well if
you read that doesn't help it might
confuse you but if you find a way to uh
decipher text phonetically with so to uh
to combine texts with listening and you
do it for a certain amount of time your
praying will get will get accustomed to
the sounds and then you will be
autonomous you will understand even more
complicated content like people talking
the radio or doing some other you know
on television and that's what I've been
doing you know phase one phase two there
are actually phases of training phases
and then once you get went to a certain
stage threshold you understand almost
everything and you become an advanced
speaker uh of uh of a given language
great okay so lots of great so far wow
uh no I the most interesting thing I
found is when you're telling that when
you speak you subtitles that's pretty
interesting yeah I I don't know how they
call it but that's that's what I see in
every language so even in Chinese I see
ping Ying I don't see characters
sometimes I see characters as well but
mostly uh I believe that this is a
consequence of what I do when people say
for example we I am more like a visual
learner or I don't I I think we're all
these all of these things in in the
sense so we can we have ears and mouth
Etc so we we have to try to use what we
have um I talked to some people who told
me well I don't I see no subtitles they
I don't see any subtitles I said well it
probably depends on the person but um I
consider I I believe that if you have
something you can see it helps you
because if you not only see that thing
you hear it so you have different you
can attack that thing from different
perspectives and it helps incredibly to
boost your capacity of retaining
information and you know I think my next
my next question is a bit related to all
what we've been talking here it's the
issue of you know just motivation
basically you just keep the work going
and you just don't give up and you know
I've been looking through um I've been
looking at a lot of polyglots on YouTube
like Moses and you know Steve Kaufman
and glossa and all these polyglass who
who' just like youve been learning so
many languages for so long and they just
never give up you know so how do you do
it how do you just keep going how do you
keep your motivation going
uh well first of all you have to
consider that if we're talking about
very passionate language Learners they
uh languages as my friend Richard said
is like he he considers himself some
kind of language langu aholic yeah um in
the sense that it's it's kind of a it's
like it's a little bit like drugs in the
sense that once you you get going you
never have enough you can never have
enough that's that's because you can you
see that it really changes your life
completely you can talk to so many
people understand different worlds and
different perspectives and that pushes
you forward so I'm talking about maybe
exceptions in the sense that the average
the average learner does it probably for
different reasons we do it out of sheer
passion that means once you get going
you keep going um so as far as I'm
concerned I can talk to you um about my
personal experience I've been learning
languages for 20 years and I see that
speaking languages is changing the way I
live and the way you see the world and
that's all in there's no
you know you talk about pros and cons of
of when you do something you do it too
much but I see no cons I see just Pros
over language learning you
know exactly so uh and then it gets
easier so in this case I'm talking about
you know um special cases in the sense
that these people are extremely
passionate about what they're doing but
I I also believe that there's a lot of
people who do it for different reasons
for example if they have to work uh they
have to go live in a I don't know in a
foreign country or they have to learn a
language because they have to for some
reason for work or for other reasons
then it's a little bit different they
they perceive it almost as a chore so
the first thing that you have to do is
even if you have to do something try to
make it you know Pleasant because um
language learning it can really change
your life so it's it's an it's an
ability that you acquire and the other
thing is that you have to find a way to
um you know at the beginning might be a
little bit different it might be a
little bit difficult to choose uh to
select for example language series you
you like is as I said the problem is
that they impose content sometimes you
like it sometimes you don't but the the
the fact that you're discovering you're
like setting foot an unknown ground and
you're discovering something else should
you know make you happy and I I think I
believe that um the problem is that as
far as motivation is concerned is that
you have to try to study as I said a
little bit every day um and then you
have to try that you know not to burn
out that's very different and then uh
you have to constantly remind yourself
of the amazing things that can happen to
you once you speak a language you can
like imag fantasize a little bit imagine
imagine yourself talking to a cute girl
or having conversations and about
interesting conversations about a
certain culture in B getting to know
amazing people being able to enjoy a
country from a different perspective
because I think and I I saw it firsthand
that when you go to a country and you
speak language things warm up you know
even people warm up pretty quickly
example a glaring a glaring example of
this like in France there's a lot of
Americans a lot of foreigners even
Italians who consider French a little
bit you know snobbish uh a little bit F
but the thing is that uh living in
France I was treated exactly like a FR
like a French like a Frenchman and
people talk and they were very gentle
even more gentle than Italians were
considered warmer so and I enjoyed
literature philosophy very interesting
conversation that changed everything so
you have to imagine yourself uh doing
and experiencing all this those things
while you learn another very important
thing is that our brain works when when
you do something pleasant then you feel
a sense of satisfaction after that for
example after 30 minutes you feel you've
done something interesting and and and
useful in your life and that sense of
satisfaction when it arises it helps you
going it means okay I've done this today
I'm going to do it tomorrow that's like
running um I I I love running for
example and that is exactly the same
thing when you go running after you've
run you feel great and you want to do it
again at the beginning you know when you
start joging you've never done it before
it might be a little bit oh my God you
know after 30 minutes because you're not
used to it but once you get going uh
things uh start changing and you want to
do it every single day so it's not about
it's it's about you know jogging and
language learning they have a lot of
things in common when you do something
um so basically remind yourself of how
how many things uh language learning can
bring about and you have to feel I I'm
pretty sure that you will feel it a
sense of satisfaction once you've done
something interesting for you your life
and the people surround you or the first
you know oringer you approach in the
language you're learning uh you know
your first conversation these are
moments of extreme joy and satisfaction
that's for sure um so visualizing maybe
yourself in these moments and really
maybe you know motivating through that